if Nicola bully is in the river
this is the man who's confident he can
find her Peter folding an underwater
search specialist has been brought in to
help police and the family get some
answers we got us really specialist
um high frequency side scan sonar which
we've got a very high hit rate I can
find anything with that and if Nicola is
here I'm happy that we will find her the
clear evidence is the phone was by the
river the harness dog harness was by the
river so I think we that's their only
clue at the moment over the next three
to four days Peter and his team will
meticulously scan the length and breadth
of the river wire something Emergency
Services have already done but this
equipment will give a clearer picture of
what lies in the water
it was 11 days ago Nicola like usual
puts a dog in the car and drove her two
daughters to school but on her walk with
Willow she disappeared Lancashire police
say their investigation is based around
the theory she slipped into the river
but her family and friends are hopeful
she'll come home
I have two little girls who miss their
mummy desperately and we need a back
it's been such a tough time for the
girls especially but also for me
we have to find a safe and well
I can't put those girls to bed again
tonight
with no answers it's
yeah
it is a voice of utter desperation and
as the days go on everyone's concerns
increase searching stops at night time
Nicholas whereabouts remains a mystery
tomorrow another day of Hope is needed
into man Rashid Sky News Lancashire